trop de mauvaises nouvelles trop trop de
mauvaises nouvelles trop de manifs déjà
moi je dis à trop de manifs et à
d'autres faire une manif on n'y a qu'à
trop de manifs à les manifs tous les
jours manif contre le gouvernement manif
contre l'écolo pour l'écologie manif
contre les violences policières elle et
gilet jaune et blacklight metteur et
arabes together et chinois forever ah ça
y est on ne peut plus au bout d'un
moment on a envie de rouler un peu avec
la voiture aussi avec c'est vrai c'est
la vérité non mieux en plus soit dans la
vie j'ai pas de combat c'est très
compliqué pour moi moi j'ai zéro combats
aériens qui me transcende au point
d'aller à 9h à république portait une
banderole mais qui sont motivés royère
pas ce qui m'intéresse vraiment se
regardent la télé charge des trucs même
des trucs sur les arabes des formules
tête je vais aller ou non plus vraiment
que ça me touche personnellement quoi c